[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and we have finally
received official news about the Code
Geass sequel fukkatsu no Arusha or
Lelouch of the resurrection including
the release date but as excited as you
might be after over a year and a half of
waiting for any real news about the
sequel trigger warning it's not all good
news as the official Code Geass website
and various other news outlets are
reporting the sequel will not be a full
third season but rather just a single
movie that will be released in February
of 2019 when the sequel was first
announced back in November of 2016 it
was presented as a third chapter in the
story so knowing that Code Geass had two
seasons which were the first two
chapters most assumed that this new
third chapter would be a full third
season however it turns out that even
though the sequel will be officially
released more than two years after it
was first announced meaning that there
was plenty of time to create an entire
new season all we are getting is a movie
but it's not all bad news because this
movie will indeed include brand-new
material and a continuation to the Code
Geass stories so fans are getting new
official content and if this movie does
extremely well who knows maybe a new
season will be greenlit once they
realize that there is a lot of money to
be made similar things have happened in
the past in addition to the first PV
that was released over a year ago we
just received a new short teaser for the
sequel a teaser which features some
captivating shots of landscapes it's
Australia we all know it and we also see
a brief glimpse of c2 along with what
appears to be a brand new character if
you've been following our videos here on
the channel and also our discussions on
our discord server you know that for a
long time we believe that the plot of
the sequel will revolve around
discovering more about the true origins
of Geass power my good friend soul maka
in particular has been saying for a long
time that the brief scenes we see of
Kornelia visiting ancient temples in the
original pv for the sequel
evidence that she has been trying to
research Geass in order to clear her
sister Euphemia's name after what
happened in the original series and we
all know that the world of Code Geass is
fascinating and there is a lot more
going on there than might appear at
first glance as I already talked about
in many of our Code Geass videos for
example I believe that the thought
elevators and the collective unconscious
from the original series were created by
an ancient civilization known as the
Ragnar s and the power of Geass
originated with this ancient
civilization this new character that we
see in the teaser definitely looks a lot
different than the rest of the
characters in the series and we even see
some lines on the characters face that
look a lot like the lines on the faces
of the ancient Geass users that we see
in the Geass sequences or flashbacks
however you want to call them so my
guess is that the new plot will be
centered around discovering the origins
of Geass and the ancient civilization
known as the Ragnar s who first
constructed the thought elevators this
new character might be a descendant of
this ancient civilization and he or she
might be trying to protect the secret of
Geass from being discovered since I
personally loved the interesting world
that Code Geass establishes I am
definitely excited about the prospect of
learning more about Geass power and its
origins and since I always believed that
Lelouch survived being stabbed by Suzaku
at the end because he had obtained code
from Charles and became immortal and I
even made videos on this I could easily
get on board with this sequel even
though obviously I wish we were talking
about a full-season rather than a movie
because it is extremely difficult to
follow up on a 50 episode iconic anime
with a brief movie sequel however as I
said if the movie is successful who
knows what could happen my big problem
and yes there is a problem is this the
three recap movies that came out in the
past year were not just recap movies I
wish they were but they weren't usually
I don't pay attention to recap films at
all because I feel such films may be
good in terms of getting someone who
hasn't seen the anime interested in
watching it but after watching the anime
seeing a movie trying to condense the
story you love is just torture in my
opinion anyway I don't know how you guys
feel
but with these Code Geass films there
have been some major changes to the
story and I don't mean just cutting out
to the story because of time constraints
I mean things like changing the fact
that Shirley shot Valletta in the
original series in order to protect
Lelouch to diit hard shooting her
instead of Shirley this is a ridiculous
change in my opinion because while I
love both Valletta and Shirley shooting
Valletta was a crucial moment of
character development for Shirley she is
a kind and innocent person a person who
doesn't want to harm anyone but her love
for Lelouch leads her to do things that
she could never have done otherwise and
that is such an important aspect of her
character but if changing that wasn't
enough Shirley doesn't die in the recap
movies she is still alive and present as
Emperor Lelouch is stabbed by Suzaku in
the z-row costume at the end of the
story like what this means that the
creators of Code Geass have established
an alternate timeline with the film's a
timeline that doesn't match up with the
original story if you want to know more
about the changes in the recap films I
will link to a fox and anime video in
the description he did a good job of
going over everything so there's no
point of me repeating it here but
needless to say these changes have
really upset me not because I want
Shirley to be dead I loved her as a
character and her death was for me the
single most heartbreaking moment in the
entire story I am upset because I
considered the creation of an alternate
timeline to be a total cop-out it means
that fukkatsu no Dhanush will not be a
true sequel to the original story we
love instead it will be an alternate
what-if scenario that we can easily just
ignore now I can understand how a show
like steins gate that is based around
time-travel and alternate timelines can
make a sequel like steins gate 0 but to
do that to a completely differential
like Code Geass feels wrong to me it's
basically saying hey if you like the
sequel great but if you don't then just
pretend like it never happened and
that's not how a writer should ever
approach their own story and I know what
you're thinking but bro you would so
hype why are you no longer hype well
random person from Denmark I will still
give the sequel a chance and if it is
popular I hope that an entire series
will come out of this but if we do get a
series I wanted to follow the original
not be some alternate timeline if as a
writer and a creator you have the
courage to create a sequel to an already
beloved in establish
to work then you should have the courage
to make it a true sequel and not a
what-if scenario but that is my opinion
let me know what you guys think are you
still excited for the Code Geass sequel
or has the alter and timeline stuff
soured it for you a bit let me know down
in the comments you don't have to agree
with me I completely respect different
opinions if you want to discuss the
sequel feel free to join our discord
server link in the description the
entire server is set up as a tribute to
Code Geass and there are many hardcore
fans in there that you can talk to just
stay up to date on all the latest Code
Geass info be sure to subscribe to this
channel and hit that notification bell
as always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]